this episode was made possible by
Skillshare get your first two months
free by following the link below our
modern world is full of specialized jobs
professional waterslide tester chocolate
engineer corn deep Tassler all unusual
jobs but then there are wine detectives
elite wine experts whose job it is to
determine the authenticity of expensive
bottles of wine and often track down the
bad guys who made the counterfeit it's a
challenging job as counterfeits are
often hard to spot especially without
opening the bottle but when choice wines
can fetch tens or even hundreds of
thousands of dollars you can see why
wine detectives are in high demand
counterfeit fine wines have become a
huge problem in the past few years with
one expert reporting to have documented
over five million dollars worth of fake
wines in the past year alone like any
professional these wine detectives have
their own specialized set of tools to
help identify fakes these tools include
jewellers loops razors colored lights
magnifying glasses flashlights and
innumerable other gadgets but they also
have a much more interesting trick up
their sleeve in high-tech laboratories
around the world physicists are able to
test suspicious wine for trace amounts
of caesium-137
the radioactive fingerprints of wine
manufactured during the Atomic Age as
most people know generally speaking the
older of vintage wine the more valuable
it can potentially be one definitive way
to determine whether a wine was actually
made before the detonation of the first
atomic bombs is to measure the amount of
cesium 137 present in the product if the
wine was really made pre-1945 it
shouldn't contain any radioactive
content cesium is not a naturally
occurring substance it didn't exist on
earth until we started blowing up atomic
bombs over time this cesium permeated
our atmosphere working its way into the
air soil and water when it rained the
cesium contained in the water would seep
into grapes and the soil at vineyards
around the world and stay there okay
story time it's not often you hear a
story that involves Thomas Jefferson
atomic bombs and over half a million
dollars in wine fraud back in 1985 an
intriguing bottle of wine came up for
auction in London the vintage was
impressive enough a 1787 Lafitte but
what was really interesting was a set of
initials carved into the bottle thj the
auction house said that the evidence
suggested the bottle had come from a
collection of French
which once belonged to Thomas Jefferson
the Forbes family bought the item for a
cool hundred fifty-seven thousand
dollars the highest price paid for any
auction wine in history at that point
once word got out that more Jefferson
bottles were discovered the
ultra-wealthy began snapping them up as
soon as they became available Bill Koch
one part of the billionaire Koch
brothers purchased four bottles for
$500,000 in 2005 the Museum of Fine Arts
in Boston was preparing an exhibit on
cokes Jefferson wine collection and
needed to verify their authenticity the
interesting thing about Jefferson is
that he was an absurdly thorough record
keeper and the leading wine connoisseur
of the Republic in over sixty thousand
documents the vintage of these prized
Jefferson bottles was never mentioned
Jefferson never ordered them coke had
been duped and others with him each of
the Bordeaux coke had bought contained
cesium-137 even though Jefferson died a
hundred years before the first atomic
blast Bill Koch was more than a little
upset at being swindled so he brought
out the big guns
Jim Elroy a former FBI agent Elroy
assembled an elite team of wine experts
including a former Scotland Yard
inspector from England and a former mi5
agent in Germany the team did their job
and caught the perpetrator or rather two
different perpetrators at least one of
the Jefferson bottles contained no
cesium which means it was actually
bottled before 1945 unfortunately for
the counterfeiter the carved initials
didn't look as authentic under closer
inspection and were traced back to a
dental tool that certainly didn't exist
in Jefferson's time that end was tied up
but what about the bottles that did
contain caesium coke decided to have his
entire collection tested and sure enough
out of his vast fifty thousand bottle
collection over 200 were determined to
be counterfeit each of them traced back
to the same source the notorious Rudi
car neon in a way Kearny Awan is an
artist he didn't just throw junk wine
into convincing bottles he came up with
his own impressively accurate recipes to
fake historic wines and these recipes
often called for a mix of already
expensive ones he was also a shrewd
opportunist the collector or investment
wine industry has exploded over the last
several years growing by at least triple
in the last decade and has become an
over 300 million dollar behemoth Kearny
Owen figured that if he could make a
convincing enough bottle most investors
would never open them
and even if they did his mixtures were
accurate enough to fool all but the most
educated wine snob unfortunately for the
self-made wine alchemist he
underestimated angry billionaires and is
currently serving a 10-year prison
sentence for fraud so the next time
you're thinking about getting into the
counterfeit wine game pick a vintage
after 1945 and use period appropriate
tools to engrave initials and also
probably don't get into the counterfeit
wine game but if you do decide to learn
how it's done head over to skill share
and follow along with expert wine
fraudsters that's not a thing if you
want to learn something other than
counterfeiting wine check out any of
skill shares over 20,000 classes they
have everything from photography to
graphic design to productivity marketing
fine art and more
I love skill share because anytime I'm
bored I can just put on a class and
learn something worthwhile a premium
membership gives you unlimited access to
high-quality classes on must know topics
so you can improve your skills unlock
new opportunities and do the work you
love I'm actually working on my own
intro to photography course I'm not
gonna give you an estimate on when it'll
be done because it's taking much longer
than I expected but it will be available
for you to watch at some point in the
near future join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for you
guys get two months of Skillshare
completely free to start learning
amazing new skills today visit skill
share by following the link below if you
enjoyed this episode make sure to leave
a comment or a thumbs up it really does
help and if you'd like to be notified of
future videos go ahead and subscribe and
click the notification gel to keep up
with the latest content if you'd like to
watch past videos check out these
playlists as always thanks for watching
and we'll see you next week
[Music]